[Music]
straight ahead
all law and crime daily a murder
happened 17 years ago
we don't ever give up an arrest in the
cold case murder of newborn twins
how police got their big break a
kentucky state commission declines to
appoint a new special prosecutor in the
briana taylor case
the meeting that ended in outcry
plus a shakeup in accused kenosha
shooters defense team
why prosecutors are raising ethical
concerns about kyle rittenhouse's
attorney
and a texas high school football player
rushes the field
then slams the referee the play that
ended with the defensive lineman kicked
out of the game
and into jail law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
illinois police announced a breakthrough
in the cold case
of two newborn twins found dead by a
waste management employee
emptying trash bins in 2003.
she saw the bodies in the front bucket
of her garbage truck
a subsequent autopsy determined that the
victims were born alive
and died of a fixation and the deaths
were ruled homicides
sheriff's police conducted a thorough
investigation at that time
but the case remained unsolved
in 2018 sheriff's police reopened the
case and utilized dna
from evidence recovered from the scene
in an effort to identify the birth
mother
using the latest developments in genetic
genealogy
a breakthrough from that research
and subsequent investigations detectives
to eventually identify briley as the
victim's potential
birth mother antoinette briley is facing
two counts of first degree murder
for the deaths of her newborn twins
about 17 years ago
police say they conducted a thorough
investigation in 2003
but the case remained unsolved
investigators reopened the case in 2018
using the same genetic genealogy
techniques used to catch the golden
state killer
as part of the investigation sheriff's
police detectives traveled to holland
michigan
and obtained discarded items
with briley's dna which was then
matched to the dna from the victims
on thursday sheriff's police learned
that briley was
in cook county and took her into custody
after traffic stop
in oaklawn illinois briley was
transported to the sheriff's police
headquarters here in maywood
where she admitted post miranda to her
involvement in the birth
death and disposal of the two deceased
infants as always terry austin is here
to break down this case and joining us
is defense attorney and former
prosecutor
bernardo violina terry let's start with
you a 17 year old
cold case concludes with a single arrest
and the one question that keeps bouncing
around in my head is
where's the father in all this you know
it's a great question brian
maybe the father was unaware of the
birth it could very well be that this
mother
had the children and then she decided to
sadly discard it you know
and asphyxiate them apparently and so
i'm thinking that perhaps they can still
do
this genetic genealogy and maybe trace
it back to the father and determine
whether or not
he did know about this and whether or
not charges should be brought against
him as well
yeah it's kind of interesting he's
either going to be a suspect or a victim
in all this
bernarda after they arrested briley she
confessed to her involvement so i'm
thinking
dna plus confession do you see this
actually being a trial case
so brian it's going to be a very
difficult case to prove because of the
passage of time and how much evidence
may have been lost and witnesses that
the people haven't been able to talk to
which doesn't work in the benefit of
either party
so i don't see this actually being a
trial i'm hoping that the prosecution in
this case
decides to plead this case out because
it's not a strong case
i would definitely keep eyes on this
case and keep looking again where's the
father
more information being collected a lot
of investigation that still needs to be
done here
turning now to missouri where an arrest
has been made in the saint louis area
for the murder of a pregnant woman and
her fetus law and crimes angela levy
tells us what helped police
identify the suspect amethyst killian
was
five months pregnant with a baby boy
when she was stabbed to death
late last month killian was a mother to
two other children
the prosecutor in saint charles missouri
outside of saint louis
says killian was stabbed more than 20
times in the head and neck
this man damien delgado faces a first
degree murder charge for the death of
killian
and a second-degree murder charge for
her fetus
prosecutor tim lomar says blood found on
a knife at the scene and nearby
matched delgado and that they used a
texting app to arrange a meeting that
turned
fatal so it was not a random killing
further investigation revealed
that delgado was seen on surveillance
video
about 10 to 15 minutes before he met up
with
the victim at a local gas station
department of revenue records were
reviewed and his photo was compared to
the surveillance video
we had a positive id the victim
and delgado had connected with one
another online
and they had arranged a meeting that
night in the early morning hours
of november 26th the prosecutor in this
case says that damian delgado has
very little criminal records so the
motive in this case remains unclear
mostly because damian delgado isn't
talking
for law and crime daily i'm angenette
levy
thanks indiana for that story and still
ahead on law and crime daily
a texas high school player gets ejected
from the field then winds up in the
slammer
the move caught on camera plus a state
commission denies brianna taylor's
mother's request
to appoint a new special prosecutor why
some are calling out the decision
[Music]
next
a kentucky board has rejected a bid for
a new prosecutor in the briana taylor
case
taylor was killed in her louisville home
by police executing a no-knock search
warrant
the state's attorney general daniel
cameron was appointed to prosecute any
potential cases
but only one of the officers involved is
charge none are facing charges for her
death
taylor's mother asked the state
commission to appoint a new prosecutor
the kentucky prosecutor's advisory
council said in a virtual hearing
that it doesn't have the legal authority
to do so an announcement
that was met with outrage simply put
we do not have the legal authority
to fulfill the request that has been
submitted
i would make a motion uh
that this finding be the position of the
prosecutor's advisory council
so all in favor of adopting the
statements as related from chris coron
and second by courtney baxter uh
this packed statement all in favor
any oppose yes
opposed
uh suppose the council has accepted the
uh
statement unanimously and so therefore
it will show that i suppose
you're wrong and you know it
kentucky attorney general daniel cameron
announced an indictment of brent
hankinson for wanton endangerment
back in october we presented all of the
information
and they ultimately made a determination
about
whether to charge in this instance they
decided to indict
detective hankinson well what my role as
the special prosecutor in this case
was to provide the information and facts
to the grand jury
detective cosgrove and sergeant
mattingly
were justified in returning fire because
they were fired upon
the governor of virginia signed
brianna's law banning no knock warrants
statewide
the attorney for taylor's family
benjamin crump says legislation can help
prevent more deaths
like taylor's in the future
kentucky attorney general
daniel cameron will not
define the legacy of brianna taylor
brianna taylor's legacy will be defined
by people of good will
brianna taylor's legacy will be
defined by people who believe
in due process of the law
back with me our attorneys bernardo
villalona and terry austin
terry attorneys representing brianna
taylor's family said in this
in the statement that you just heard the
council quote
punted on the issue inaccurately
claiming that they lack the authority to
actually fulfill this request
what are some of your thoughts and
comments to benjamin crump's
comments as to the council you know i
agree with
trump actually it is a very odd
situation here yes we have a settlement
on the civil side and yes we have briana
taylor's law
but we don't have a criminal conviction
of the individuals who actually were
responsible
for her death and so i do think there's
some level of cowardice here
i think that you know the police
department certainly the attorney
general's office
and now we see that this council they
all are
really trying to evade the criminal
process here and i think trump and i
think taylor's family
has a right to be outraged we've seen
evidence
that there's more to this story now
bernard this has been a long
saga when it comes to brianna taylor but
in terms of having someone charge for
the actual death
of brianna taylor is this the end of the
road for any potential criminal charges
that's what it looks like brian well
actually no because remember the feds
are still investigating the case they
have not closed
their their investigation into what
happened that night so that
is still a possibility and a road that
the family can
have hope to hold on to so i guess we
just have to wait and see how that
investigation plays out but currently no
one is being
charged for the death of brianna taylor
only as we said earlier brett hankinson
for the wanton endangerment coming up on
law and crime daily
a deadly police shooting in ohio why the
man's family is calling for an
independent investigation
plus ethical concerns raised in the
kenosha shooting suspect's defense
why prosecutors say one of kharan
house's attorneys should be off the case
next
[Music]
prosecutors in the kyle renthouse case
are raising ethical concerns
over one of the high-profile attorneys
for the kenosha shooting suspect
los angeles civil attorney john pierce
announced he's offering house his
criminal team
the same day prosecutors filed a motion
saying pierce should not be allowed to
represent the defendant
pierce helped raise two million dollars
for rent house's bail
kenosha county assistant district
attorney thomas binger
alleged that pierce has quote
significant personal financial
difficulties
and money that should be held in trust
for the defendant
may be used to repay attorney pierce's
numerous
creditors pierce tweeted out that he'll
still be representing written house's
civil matters
rittenhouse appeared in virtual in a
virtual hearing with his wisconsin
attorney
mark richards terry
let me let me read the prosecutor's
allegations here and just quote it here
attorney pierce's personal financial
difficulties raise significant ethical
concerns
specifically when he has close ties to a
substantial yet unregulated and
unreported quote slush fund that is
intended solely for the benefit of the
defendant
this seems more like a warning than
actually saying there's a problem here
but the timing of the attorney stepping
off the criminal case does
raise an eyebrow or two what are your
thoughts
well it is quite odd that the
prosecution is looking into
the personal finances of pearce what
difference does it make
whether or not pierce has a lot of money
or a little bit of money i think the
real
issue here is whether or not the funds
that pierce has raised
is in a trust and it should be and
whether or not the funds are being used
for
his clients defense and that's really
all that matters
what i will tell you brian is the timing
is a bit
odd that pierce withdrew from the
criminal case just as the prosecution
raised
this issue it's as though he wants to
avoid
any more scrutiny yeah and bernardo let
me be devil's advocate a little bit here
and kind of think of this i've got
student loans so does this mean that if
i start representing a high profile
person
i'm going to get a prosecutor looking at
how much i owe because maybe i'm going
to start
spending it on my student loans like
this seems a little ridiculous what do
you think
so brian what it sounds like to me
because of course this is not normally
done you know i was a prosecutor for 16
years and i'm not looking into the
background of every defense attorney
i think that it's possible that there
may be an investigation that the
prosecution is giving
whiff of to the defense attorney so
because the defense attorney thinks that
oh
something may be going on he's like let
me back up and take the attention away
from myself
but in the end all that matters is that
mr rittenhouse
is afforded with his constitutional
right to representation
all right bernard let's talk worst case
scenario uh
this attorney let's say he's skimming a
little off the top when it comes to
funds
what happens to an attorney when they do
that other than obviously just barman
well aside from this fireman he's going
to be investigated and charges may
follow as a result of that
he's not immune just because he's in a
defense attorney the laws apply to
all of us so there's going to be a lot
of problems for him and
uh obviously it's going to affect mr
rayton house's
representation so the prosecution wants
to be rather safe than sorry
yeah and and terry this is like very
easy
uh rules of ethics for all lawyers don't
co-mingle funds
uh don't date your clients while they're
clients it just seems like a pretty
simple thing but do you think that
there's a potential i mean the
prosecutor was raising it that where
there's smoke there could be fire
well you know let's hope that there's
something there and he's not just
throwing these accusations around
but the real issue is what i mentioned
before the fact that
he is now doing the civil case so if
there was a problem with
the criminal case there's going to be a
problem as far as the civil
case is concerned too and ethically he
should do the same thing
for both the civil side and the criminal
side so let's hope he's not co-mingling
these funds
it's going to be interesting to see how
this plays out of course if a prosecutor
is raising this it's a pretty
uh harsh criticism without evidence but
of course we gotta wait to see how that
plays out
but when we come back a referee
blindsided as a player
tackles him to the ground the criminal
charges the defensive lineman is now
facing after the break
[Music]
the family of an ohio man killed by a
deputy is seeking answers to what
happened
leading up to his death terry austin has
more on the ongoing investigation
brian i'm still working to learn more
information but it appears the deputy
involved in the
incident was not wearing a body camera
23-year-old casey goodson jr was shot by
a franklin county sheriff's deputy
authorities say deputy jason mead was
assigned to the u.s marshals fugitive
task force
the marshals were looking for a suspect
when they encountered goodson jr
they say he was waving a gun a
confrontation
ensued and goodson was shot his family
disagreed saying he was shot in the back
while walking into his own home his
family also claims
that he had a concealed carry permit
goodson jr was not the suspect
investigators were searching for brian
the combination of no body worn camera
what the officers are
saying waving a gun as a as a registered
gun owner then being shot in the back
it seems so hard to kind of to mesh
together
uh terry we've seen this where there's
no body camera
video and it doesn't really go anywhere
do you think this means the case may not
go to the grand jury
you know i i hope it does because this
is a serious case the fact that there
was no
body cam the fact that he was walking
into his
own home he wasn't carrying a gun at
least according to some of the witnesses
he was shot in the back three times he's
never been involved in a criminal matter
i think this is inexcusable i think it
should be investigated and i
absolutely positively think that there
should be a grand jury proceeding to see
whether or not charges
should be brought against the police
officers involved here
exactly some of the things we'll be
looking out for autopsy reports any
eyewitnesses of course that information
will help us
in this case thank you terry a texas
high school football player is facing
charges for rushing the field and
knocking a referee to the ground
and we have two fouls both on the
edinburgh kai
bobcats late hit on the quarterback
and we'll be back
the edinburgh school district says
emmanuel duran has been removed from the
football team
the referee had ejected the player from
the game after two penalties
one for unsportsmalite conduct durrana
is then seen running across the field
and slamming into the ref he's charged
with a class a assault
terry duron is at the end of the day an
18 year old high school student athlete
do you think that there will
be some leniency considering he's still
in high school
you know i i know he's in high school
but 18
really is the age of adult in texas and
in most states so
i think here he should have known better
and i think that
the offense actually was very serious
the fact that he
attacked this referee is just
inexcusable he should have known better
and i think he should be
charged with assault and frankly i i do
think they should
you know throw the book at him so to
speak definitely being charged with
assault bernardo maybe it's the public
defender in me that thinks
depending on how bad the refs injuries
are and i don't know them at this point
this case could probably be resolved
with community service or some form of
probation
or do you see jail time or some sort of
trial in this kid's future
or sorry young adults future i i don't
see
jail time in this young adult's future
obviously
they have to take everything into
circumstances
in terms of what to do with him and also
taking into account that it was doing a
game
his age probably his anger and the fuel
just got the best of him but jail time
on this kind of case
no injury i highly doubt it yeah terry
maybe it's my bias as a former college
athlete myself
but it's texas it's football i feel like
it's going to be like a little bit of a
boys will be boys conversation
when he gets to the court do you see
this being handled kind of like hey man
just
maybe he has to ref football games for a
couple weeks
uh to give back to the community you see
that maybe being a resolution here
yeah i do think he's not going to get
jail time but i do think he should have
some sort of community service i think i
must have been a prosecutor in another
life or maybe in my next life because i
tend to lean
towards the more you know stringent
punishment so to speak
but i think here that we can't ignore it
i think that they should set an example
you know not too harsh but at least
hopefully he will learn
from his actions and this sort of thing
is not going to be tolerated from him
or from any of the other athletes for
that matter and that's a big if
of course i'm saying if the referee has
minor injuries
that's a big boy that's not a small a
small man running after you that's a big
boy he's a defensive linebacker so he
could have done a lot of damage and i
agree with you
if this is a student athlete who might
go to college might go to the nfl
you definitely want to kind of create
that mindset of
this is not allowed this is not proper
um
bernardo always a pleasure having you on
terry austin thank you so much for
lending your expertise as
always and thank you for joining us in
all these cases we'll continue to keep
watching them
but thank you for joining us here in the
law and crime daily we'll see you next
time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you